[Applause]
thanks Gus OG you held this Blazers team
to just 84 points tonight defensively
what stood out to you uh we were just
really connected uh we were flying
around getting stops communicating just
rebounding and pushing connected on the
other end to six different Knicks in
double figures how would you describe
the flow of the offense that we're
seeing in this five-game win streak just
fighting the open man and everyone shoo
with confidence and being aggressive 16
points for you in that first quarter
does it feel like things are kind of
clicking is you're making your way on
this team yeah I think it's getting
better and better every game OG you got
the OG chance from the garden crowd for
the first time tonight this place is so
magical what was it like to get that for
the first time from these fans oh yeah
it was really cool you know it was
really cool thanks OG gu back to you all
right Rebecca thank you very much OG on
an Obi really contributing to this
team